Contrary to your common movie villain, the
walking dead are simple, primal, and animalistic.
Still, there are all kinds of complex mysteries
surrounding their abilities and tendencies
that tend to get glossed over or go completely
unexplored.
When we think of zombies, we tend to think
of shambling undead corpses that ravenously
hunt for human flesh all day and all night…
a habit that will continue unabated so long
as they're still hooked up to those all-important
brains.
Are you with us so far?
Sure, it's disturbing… but it's also just
kind-of confusing.
Sometimes, we'll see zombies that are deformed
beyond recognition but are still quite snappy
and energetic.
And sometimes, highly decomposed zombies can
still move with the same vim and vigor they
once demonstrated in gentler, less zombified
times.
In fact, some zombies seem to move even faster
than when they were alive.
"As zombies began to outnumber humans, well
that's when you had to cut all emotional ties."
These idiosyncrasies can be somewhat explained
when a film is constrained to a very specific
timeline.
I Am Legend is set three years after the initial
outbreak, and it doesn't stray too far from
there, allowing for some continuity in regards
to those dastardly Darkseekers.
But in shows like The Walking Dead, the issue
of deterioration has become a challenge.
Much like the act of watching The Walking
Dead has become a challenge.
To give you an example, let's compare and
contrast.
Here are some terrifyingly low-key zombies
from Season One of The Walking Dead:
And here are some zombies from Season Eight
of The Walking Dead:
Yeah, they look a little worse for the wear,
but they move like they've hardly aged a day…
so what exactly is their secret?
Olay?
"Vitamin enriched, fights seven signs of aging.
In four weeks, skin looks up to 10 years younger."
As the years pass us by and the seasons drag
on and on and on, it raises an obvious question:
How and why are these jerks still moving around
at virtually the same speed as when they first
turned into zombies?
Anyone?
Every movie seems to have its own origin for
the zombie plague — if they bother to explain
it at all.
But none of them try to answer the most basic
question: What exactly goes on in these zombies'
heads?
When it comes to brain function, there's absolutely
no consistency in the world of these cold,
clammy, bloodthirsty creeps.
Some zombies move with superhuman speed and
are capable of effortlessly lifting people
into the air with their bare hands.
Meanwhile, other zombies are seemingly incapable
of even taking a brisk afternoon stroll.
For every goal-oriented zombie with drive
and determination…
"Brains!”
... there's a whole mess of zero-ambition
zombies who can barely keep it together.
No dreams.
No ambition.
This raises more puzzling questions: What
level of brain function do these undead shambling
nightmares operate on?
Are some zombies smarter than others?
"... More brains."
And if these zombies are technically dead,
how do they have any brain function in the
first place?
Any insights?
Sorry, here's something else that really bugs
us: Some zombies have the wherewithal to be
fast as hell, bounding about like young gazelles.
Other times, they're just shuffling along,
slow as snails and twice as slimy.
Like these boring zombies.
If there really are a few rudimentary thoughts
still floating around inside these zombie
brains, where exactly is the line drawn?
Do all the same rules apply to mean-spirited
zombie monkeys?
What about majestic zombie horses?
And some zombies are apparently MENSA material.
Remember that scene in World War Z, when the
undead hordes built a towering zombie ladder
to scale the wall?
Yeah, that's not the kind of thing you can
just build on pure instinct.
Even for a zombie movie, that type of behavior
is kind of a stretch.
Here's something else about zombies that we're
just supposed to accept … because we're
never given any kind of rational explanation
at all.
Why do zombies always want to eat human beings?
It's so excessive.
We're not talking about some desperate compromise
made in order to survive on a lifeboat.
Not that zombies don't like to go on a sailing
expedition every once in awhile.
When it comes to zombies and their love of
human flesh, we're talking about a culinary
preference like no other.
Whenever someone turns into a zombie, it usually
takes only a matter of seconds before they
start munching on the nearest person they
can find.
Why do zombies like human flesh and not, say,
fast food?
“I want my Whopper."
In a moment of weakness, why can't your standard-grade
zombie just engulf a bag of Cool Ranch Doritos
like everybody else?
Frankly, this unending quest for fresh human
flesh gets to be rather one-note.
And what's worse, these unstoppable killing
machines are often willing to devour the nearest
member of their family in the name of a good
old-fashioned blood meal.
“Come on, mom… come on, mom… ahhhhh!"
Enough is enough.
Can we please get some concrete answers as
to what makes these unspeakable monstrosities
tick?
"Brains!"
"Help!
Help!"
Apparently when humans die and become zombies,
their first instinct is to gather in herds.
At least, that's the takeaway from pretty
much every show about these grim, ungodly
ghouls.
Sure, there's still the occasional solo zombie
straggler that pops up from time to time,
but that's usually just for the sake of a
jump scare.
The really serious threat arrives when a gigantic
group of zombie deadbeats stumbles onto the
scene.
Whether we're talking about an intimate group
of like-minded zombies gathering in a safe
environment, or a mega-herd of zombies come
to eat everyone's brains this very instant,
the burning question remains the same: Why
is this supposed to be the natural behavior
of zombies in the first place?
They're not getting more food this way.
Just look at them.
They're going to be hungry all the time if
they insist on traveling in those kinds of
numbers… because zombies are greedy and
selfish.
"It's weird, eh?"
Whether it's the creatures in I Am Legend
or those horrific monsters in Zombieland,
these creatures almost always succumb to a
herd mentality.
Not that anyone really ever bothers to explain
why.
The closest we ever get to a concert answer
is this:
For a moment, let's turn our attention from
the undead to the living.
At their root, zombies are a bonafide medical
curiosity that cause uncontrollable outbreaks
and exhibit horrific symptoms that worsen
over time.
Some shows like The Walking Dead never confront
the quarantine issue by making the zombie
virus some sort of blanket sickness that everyone
eventually contracts.
But more often than not, containing and controlling
the outbreak is the core plot point in a zombie
film.
Take the movie Quarantine, for example.
So here's a question: if a zombie outbreak
affects continents and eventually the entire
globe, what happens to the people who live
on remote islands?
Sure, it's easy to rule out the bigger players
like Great Britain.
After all, the film 28 Days Later takes place
on that particular island nation.
But what about smaller, more out-of-the-way
locations — like that faraway island in
the life-affirmingly awful film House of the
Dead?
Does Hawaii remain an island paradise… or
does everybody who live there also get infected
in the event of a zombie virus outbreak?
What about Madagascar… is this cute little
guy gonna get turned into a zombie?
Oftentimes, a zombie outbreak is shrouded
in secrecy at the beginning of the story.
In order to ratchet up the tension, the protagonist
is often left completely in the dark regarding
the increasingly undead state of the world
around him or her.
"No, I haven't got any change."
Sometimes, it seems like the zombie apocalypse
took place while a healthy chunk of the world
was getting some good old-fashioned shut-eye.
“Sweetie, are you okay?"
Sure, that totally works for zombie stories
that came out before social media was a thing,
but films and television shows that take place
after the rise of Mark Zuckerberg needs to
start taking Facebook into account.
Let's get real here: What if this woman was
loitering around your neighborhood?
Imagine if these ghouls spontaneously erupted
from the soil of your local cemetery.
Wouldn't someone try capturing these precious
moments on their smartphone?
Wouldn't a few folks decide to share the spooktacular
sights on Instagram?
What we're trying to say here is: The idea
of a zombie apocalypse that isn't thoroughly
trumpeted on social media is patently absurd.
Not to mention totally unrealistic.
Here's another aspect of zombie anatomy that's
hard for us to wrap our heads around: They
basically live off of nothing, all the time
— and seemingly forever.
But even after they've just enjoyed some human
flesh, they still act like they're totally
starving...
They even act that way after a gosh-darned,
bonafide feeding frenzy.
Like, all these zombies literally just ate.
This zombie didn't even finish eating the
nice old lady, and now he's making moves on
this other dude?
Such a waste!
What we've learned from all of this is that
zombies are basically impossible to satisfy.
"Joey, I am not into dead guys!"
"Huh?"
Is there any rhyme or reason to this zombie
bloodlust?
Let's think rationally about it for a second.
If eighty or ninety percent of the population
are turned into zombies, it makes sense that
fresh human flesh would be a hot commodity
indeed.
But a few years down the line, it would be
nearly impossible for these zombies to find
any food to shovel into their bellies.
They evidently don't need to eat people in
order to survive — they're dead! — so
why are they always so pumped to be eating
everybody anyway?
And yet, there they go, skulking around in
search of another bite.
But if zombies are willing to snack on the
occasional dead deer like this gentleman here,
why this obsession with eating people?
And after they've chomped on an unlucky human,
do zombies ever crave something ice-cold and
refreshing to wash it all down with?
You can see the problem here.
These guys must be extremely dehydrated.
Once again, the question of nutrition becomes
particularly sticky with long-running shows
like The Walking Dead.
All these years later, how are the walkers
even moving at this point?
We're all familiar with the sight of a bloody
zombie.
In fact, no one even bats an eye at the sight
anymore.
But what about all those uninfected people
who accidentally get covered in zombie blood?
The Walking Dead literally has their heroes
cover themselves in zombie guts to sneak through
the undead zombie gridlock undetected.
How on Earth is that safe?
We know that a zombie bite is almost always
fatal and will almost definitely turn you
into a zombie.
Even a zombie scratch can become a health
hazard.
“Mark?"
"Wait…"
So how and why is it OK to be covered in fresh
zombie blood?
Why don't those humans get infected?
They're bound to have a little scratch on
them where the zombie blood can get in, right?
In the end, it's never going to make total
sense.These are all just movies about silly
made-up monsters.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.